The Joe Rogan Experience they brought
him in the White House brought him in to
talk about the pandemic apparently what
this is general information they said
they're asking about crypto if you're
gonna [ __ ] ask someone about the
pandemic would it be that guy on the
right
I mean I would love to see a
conversation between the guy on the left
Biden and the guy on the right the guy
on the left is making up words the the
guy on the right is on an amphetamines
come on man come on man secretary Jean
uh Kyrene Jean-Pierre conceded that four
meetings may have also covered general
information about crypto between senior
Biden officials were about the pandemic
like what yeah what could that [ __ ]
young kid do in speed [ __ ] his
neighbors well look here's the thing hey
nobody in the White House really
understands crypto to begin with right
it's it's it seems like very few people
understand crypto really but but it just
in terms of looking at this guy's
situation
um it's like with Bernie Madoff if you
had gone and if someone had taken the
time early days with Madoff said I'm
gonna go visit you know some Basics I'm
gonna go look where his accountant sits
oh really he's sitting in a [ __ ]
small office in a strip mall and yet
this guy's supposed to be you know king
of the world well how about these guys
you know what they were using
Quick Books oh yeah yeah yeah they were
using Quick Books the [ __ ] that like a
guy uses if he has a [ __ ] small
bookstore yeah they're using that you
just I mean you compile information and
maybe one or two pieces of it like okay
you look at the guy and go this guy
doesn't look like a a rocket scientist
and and you know he his lifestyle you
look at lifestyle issues maybe they're
bizarre but you compile as much
information about the entire apparatus
as possible and I would argue that
anybody in their right mind if they had
taken the time to do significant due
diligence would have stepped back and
said ah no not doing this guy you know I
don't care how many celebrities he's got
put in there and you know anything he
was going after celebrities for a reason
just like your name over in Arena right
because it gives you [ __ ] credibility
the same reason why he's donating so
much money yes and and you know the
donations anybody who thinks he wasn't
doing that to exert leverage or to
gather information you know uh again
naive ignorant you know whatever well
his mother was a big time Democratic
operative too right yeah so that was
probably part of his connection
yeah it's just it's a shame because you
know a lot of people were hurt you know
whether they claw that money back or not
millions of people yeah and you know
some of the some of the folks in the
Democratic party are saying well we're
going to give some money back but how
it's going to be yeah where's the money
where is it coming from if if the
money's all nonsense which is what a lot
of crypto is it once it collapses it's
nonsense there's no legitimate assets
right right and then you have to also
ask yourself and I think you know some
of the there's some coverage I think
there's going to be more talking about
the nature of trading again you know
wash trades are illegal in the financial
industry for a reason right but explain
wash trades again uh it's um
what's the way to it's like okay it's
like with my my book you know you might
have heard about my book I heard about
it yeah it's being released on the 18th
of January on script uh how does this
have to do with anything are you just
I'm going to tell you I'm going to tell
you if I if I really was desperate and I
said I really want my book to become a
bestseller right well one of the things
I could do is I could set up I could set
up a bunch of fake uh accounts on Amazon
or whatever
and then I could put money into those
all those different accounts and then I
could start buying up my book I know
someone who did that you did that's why
it's in a sense that's a wash rate is
that you're on both sides right uh it's
illegal in the financial industry but
see remember crypto is
what is this it's not a currency it's a
it's a it's a it's a piece of property
it's a you know so it's they haven't
decided they're still trying to figure
it out right which again I would argue
is one of the reasons why you know SPF
was putting money into politics you know
if you can get ahead of the game I'll
tell you as an example as you know
there's a reason why I'm telling the
story early days of Iraq I'm talking
like 2003 2004 2005.
um
my company had you know a lot of people
there because we were supporting
security operations for a lot of the
infrastructure companies you know and so
they're out there trying to rebuild
parts of the country they're doing
things well they've got to have security
and they've got people handling a
variety of problems with them so we had
gotten out there very early we were out
there in early 2003 right at the very
beginning and
um
it didn't take long you know at first
there were several months where it was
relatively peaceful [ __ ] started to hit
the fan out there in about September of
2003 right really started going south
and it started getting violent and
there's a 2004 2005 the security
business in Iraq just ballooned right
suddenly you couldn't swing at that cat
without hitting another security company
they just popped up out of nowhere you
know you'd be out there and say who are
you guys with and they'd say some
company you'd never heard of right and
just put together because people saw
opportunity I'm gonna get some
government contracts right I'm going to
come and work for these companies I'm
gonna do this and they were pulling
people who had no business being out in
a hostile environment right and
providing security
um
so then they started having problems do
all sorts of issues well
we started thinking okay this has got to
get regulated right state department and
and Pentagon they're going to come in
they're going to so no we've got to
regulate the private security industry
that's operating out here we know we
need it but it's just unregulated so
we're going to do so
as part of that once we realized that
was going to happen we got together with
some of the more reputable security
firms that were operating out there who
said let's form an association right so
that we can get ahead of the curve right
and we can help Define what the
regulations are for these security
companies that are out there operating
it's in our best interest right and I
would argue it's no different than what
you know SPF was doing you know kind of
spreading the cash around
so that he can understand where the
regulations were going to come from and
he could get ahead of the curve and and
you know so
hey from a Intel perspective you know
Bravo that's the right intuition
but uh again he didn't recognize his
vulnerability